hot breath how did you decide the order
for your set
well that one for the order of my set
it's weird because when i was running it
at the creek and i thought about it
i split it up into two
minute chunks or two 20 to 25 minute
chunks
um because it's easier for me to
memorize i have a really hard time
memorizing stuff i don't it's like a
mental block for me so
i find it yucky i don't like doing it so
i don't
attempt and the only way that i can do
it is if i keep doing things over and
over again where it becomes a muscle
memory but the
idea of actively memorizing something is
so awful
um so i broke it down into two
20 25 minute chunks and then i i could
remember it that way so i could
flip them around and i would do that as
as i was running sets in the city which
would help me memorize
knowing that i didn't have to have them
in that exact order but if i knew it
then it would make me feel comfortable
on stage so
i was starting off with my second half
as my first half
and then i realized i felt like it might
be it had a lot more weirder
and dirtier like vulgar stuff maybe or
sex stuff
and i always think and just as watching
stand up throughout the times everybody
usually puts their dirtier or weirder
stuff towards the
end because you want the audience
especially for an album and somebody
doesn't know you that well
i think it's good to have them trust you
and kind of know what your voice is
before you start
doing stuff like that so they know that
you're not
serious and that you're only making fun
of everything and you don't
like for me i didn't have i wanted
you to not really know what my strong
opinion is
like irreverent so i think that's why i
put the cleaner stuff
up front and then i went with the um uh
the dirtier stuff and the weirder stuff
towards the end
yeah it's almost like you get them on
your side and then they'll go wherever
you want to go
but if you opened with your closer that
would set a completely different
um expectation for this turn it off
and then also from there it's like hard
to follow your
observational bits when you've liked
talked about your genitals or whatever
you know what i mean
like i'll notice that when i have to
follow a certain comics on stage
if they're like if they're particularly
vulgar
which is fine because i'm vulgar too but
like
to follow that in a different energy and
then you're going up there talking about
your printer or avocados then the crowd
is like
what yeah like it takes a while to reset
and so it just makes it very difficult
so i'm like why would i set myself up
for failure
in my own set so i'd i decided with that
to start with the cleaner stuff up front
and the more relatable broader
topics and did you have like
a set list and are your set lists um
like pen to paper are you in your phone
are they keywords are they phrases how
do you do that
um my set loops i keep i so i have like
two notebooks i have a notebook that i
just kind of free write in um
and then i have my set list that i
actually use probably more often than my
actual joke book and it's just um
all all that my sets that i'm working
with and
um i usually flip back sometimes i
forget a joke i accidentally drop one as
time goes by and then
i get to flip through my set list and be
like oh yeah i forgot about that i
should bring that back
here or that goes better with this bit
now
so yeah i just i write the same
even when i know i already have my set
list memorized i write it because it's
like
a nervous tick before show it makes me
feel better to at least
feel like i'm in that mindset to like go
up on stage if i write my set list
yeah i do every every show i'm i'm
making a set list
like even if i know the jokes it yeah it
just keeps me in that mode of like
i'm not here just killing time i'm here
working on
something yeah you you gotta go up with
a little bit of a plan or something to
fall back on i mean you can go up on the
stage and like you know start doing
crowd work
but like once they start getting settled
you can go as long as you know what
you're doing
it kind of makes me feel comfortable
yeah and this is uh stefan
saying he loves the new album and your
bit about
people crying in public is hilarious oh
yeah
that's the new york thing oh there's so
many good ones